[Music]
ah we all know the old adage when life
gives you lemons we learn legal terms
eric palacios from eric palacios and
associates the sponsors of this segment
tells us how to know when your car is a
lemon
i'm eric palacios and welcome to this
week's legal minute the question we have
is how do i know if my car is a lemon
you need to keep three things in mind
number one to be a lemon you must have
purchased your car new
and you must have the same problem with
it at least four times during a one year
period or within the warranty period or
if your car was out of service for at
least 30 days straight then it can also
be classified as a lemon
number two what can you do if this is
the case you can return it to the
dealership and ask for a refund or you
can ask the dealer to exchange it for a
similar car the dealer cannot refuse one
of these two options
number three what will happen to your
car after that
your car has to be rebranded as a lemon
before it's sold again
this has been the legal minute don't
forget to download my free app eric
palacio's legal app we'll see you next
week
for more information more for more
information you can give eric palacios
and associates a call that's the number
702-444-7770